[Música]
se dice que el día que hernán cortez
llegó a la península de yucatán lo hizo
a bordo de 11 galeones lo acompañaban
también 500 soldados y una tripulación
aproximadamente de 300 hombres su misión
era clara él debía tomar control del
imperio azteca
en aquel entonces era una misión osada y
pretenciosa quedó también para la
historia que una vez arriban en la
península de yucatán cortes con antorcha
en mano fue y quemó y hundió cada uno de
esos barcos el mensaje fue claro a pesar
de la incertidumbre y el miedo que
también lo acompañaba no había más
remedio que ir hacia adelante tomémonos
un segundo y pensemos que podría pasar
que puede pasar el día que como corte
andamos cada uno de esos galeones que
nos cobijan del miedo que nos brindan
certeza y que nos hacen sentir seguros
en colombia la población nació infantil
de primera infancia que son esos niños
que están entre los 3 y los 7 años
usualmente vive en procesos de
vulneración de sus derechos está
hablando de procesos como el abuso el
abandono el maltrato y la negligencia
lamentablemente de estas situaciones en
una huella emocional en el desarrollo
psicoafectivo del niño sin embargo
nosotros encontramos la forma de
transformar la vida de estos niños sus
habilidades emocionales y sus
habilidades psicoafectivas esto lo
pudimos encontrar a través del caballo
si el caballo para entender un poco la
historia de por que el caballo tenemos
que irnos entonces casi 25 mil años
atrás en aquel entonces
el hombre del paleolítico los soñadores
los observadores los curiosos los
creativos los artistas de entonces ya
fantaseaban con este colosal animal que
se agrupaban en manadas que interactuaba
a través del trabajo en equipo la
comunicación y sobre todo en el
liderazgo
esta fascinación entonces de juego lo
que hoy conocemos como el arte rupestre
y una vez el hombre incorpora el caballo
a su vida lo hacemos nuestro medio de
transporte fue nuestro compañero en el
desarrollo de los procesos agrícolas ya
la misma forma mongoles persas romanos
macedonios estuvieron con él en el
momento que expandieron sus imperios
pero el caballo no es la fascinación
solamente del hombre primitivo
el caballo también es la fascinación de
un niño una vez el niño entra en
contacto con un caballo el caballo se
vuelve el efecto de ese afecto el niño
paradójicamente empieza a albergar a
albergar al niño al caballo en su
corazón
es anecdótico pensar cómo puede cavar
caber un animal de tal talla en un
corazón que es del tamaño del puño de
una mano pero entonces como esto es
posible
esto es posible entonces a través de
nuestro programa de desarrollo asistido
con caballos
el desarrollo asistido con caballos es
un programa que combina la pedagogía la
psicología la antropología la sociología
y por supuesto la etología equina
qué sucede en estos programas
los niños se empiezan a interactuar a
través de unas dinámicas que se
desarrollan desde la pedagogía se
observan desde la psicología y que están
orientadas a generar un compartir en
donde el trabajo en equipo el respeto la
comunicación y sobre todo la reflexión
empiezan a desarrollar cinco habilidades
en el niño estamos hablando de la
comunicación del trabajo en equipo del
respeto de la tolerancia y de la
autoconfianza el niño va a necesitar
estas cinco habilidades porque
eventualmente el niño va a entrar en
contacto con el caballo
el caballo le va a enseñar al niño a
hacer ejercicio de su liderazgo el
caballo le enseña al niño a liderar a
través del ejemplo a través del servicio
a poner sus habilidades en pro del
colectivo pero también el caballo le
exige al niño que desarrollo las
relaciones con él en el marco de esas
cinco habilidades previamente que el
niño ha desarrollado
cuál es el resultado el resultado es un
niño completamente hábil en sus procesos
de comunicación es un niño que aprende a
regular y balancear sus emociones es un
niño que empieza a transformar la forma
como se relacionaba con sí mismo y cómo
empieza a relacionarse con su entorno
pero porque consideramos que estos niños
deben de llevar estas habilidades con sí
mismos
eventualmente esos niños van a verse
enfrentados a la oportunidad de un
proceso de adopción de estos niños van a
tener una segunda oportunidad esos niños
van a empezar a generar interacciones y
la construcción de relaciones con nuevos
entornos y con nuevas personas desde
niño entonces va a poner en el servicio
de esas nuevas personas y de esos nuevos
entornos las habilidades que ha
aprendido para relacionarse en el marco
del programa
en ese momento nosotros sentimos que
trascendemos en ese momento nosotros
empezamos a influenciar un entorno en el
que nunca hemos estado y a la misma
manera influenciar unas personas con las
que nos hemos cruzado todo a través de
las enseñanzas del niño que sembramos en
él y que él impone el ejercicio para la
construcción de esas relaciones con la
nueva familia
valió la pena hundir los barcos valió la
pena apostar por esa tarea osada y
pretenciosa de ese hundimiento emergió
la fundación paso trote galope esta es
una organización socialmente innovadora
que surgió como una iniciativa
filantrópica que se viene gestando en la
ciudad de cali desde el año 2013 y que
su principal objetivo es fomentar y
desarrollar la inteligencia emocional y
la conciencia colectiva en la primera
infancia todo a través del poder
transformador del caballo
hoy
hoy hemos tenido la oportunidad de
compartir con más de 50 niños de
transformar su vida en la medida que
también transformarla de nosotros mismos
hemos tenido la felicidad de saber que
más de 25 de esos niños hoy duermen en
un hogar adoptivo en un hogar que les
dio una segunda oportunidad
todo esto nos dejó claro dos cosas la
primera es posible transformar el mundo
con el caballo y la segunda es que
mientras existan estas posibilidades sin
duda es en el lomo del caballo como
estos niños llegan a los hogares que los
estamos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]